they've got one called subway shootout
artillery mentor I pay my pants I'm on
France crossbow battle bloody what the
[ __ ] is bloody conference look I'm gonna
literally pee my pants just Knight come
no night-night come my scum night I'm
concerned about what's happening on my
screen I opened up the character editor
as a character yeah there's a character
editor now and I don't know if this is
the D part or one night in the middle of
the night slept walked and created this
just tell me if yours is just as
disturbing as mine is the outfit you're
wearing something even Amy wouldn't
approve huh
why wouldn't Namie approve of this Oh
bikini bottom is worse than dawn panties
here we go Oh or better
mmm bikini bikini bottom bikini bottom
I get it now huh bikini bottom
yeah it's the bottom part of the bikini
but like spongebob right pants the Santa
man sweet Jesus I know right mark stop
that bikini bottom pretty sure that's
against terms sir
but Katie Bob wait so if I have this
outfit only you guys are gonna see it so
then your streams will be against Terms
of Service what I'll just never look at
you no matter what is happening I'll
never look at you yeah I'm not looking
this paired none
that sounds fitting for me [ __ ] good one
dude man I love your laugh yeah my real
laugh yeah I save it for my real friends
oh wait just just start a conversation
with me the conversation skills
Oh
Bob why are you where are you standing
in the middle what by are you both Santa
know what his hair that was not me
why are you sakes why is this happening
to me just press the button I think
everything will be fine
oh god my hands getting worse what in
God's name are the controls press f1
it's good woah
Bob listen man why do you have a good
why do you have a gun I Bob did you load
the wrong game-mode No am I the only one
has a gun right now personally went
through the pin not that oh no I didn't
sleep oh that was loud and bone no I
dropped all the bullets for my gun go
back and try to do the right game-mode I
didn't even touch a grenade I can't see
you you're facing where mark spawn
didn't last time I know I'm in like the
same place oh god I pushed the button I
see you across the tracks I see you yeah
okay that's you okay across the tracks
oh I see you in the you're in the stairs
wait wait you're in the wrong place
mark and I are at things you're in the
wrong place it's starting oh I clicked
restart but we're still not what wait
what do you see I see me standing at my
normal spot then you get Bob standing in
the middle by one of the concrete we're
all fine it's I look where the boxes are
that's where we are it doesn't matter
what we see to each other it just
matters what you see to you okay so just
no panicking just some panicked
are you panicked no I'm not panicked I'm
getting my gun ready to shoot you
why do you why do you have a gun what do
you have this is grenade spam no it's
clearly not have guns I don't know what
happened this is why we have an issue
because I created a grenade spam game
and you guys are you playing good
dumb button there's no random button no
not here when you were making the server
no why not there was no random button
okay faster farther scary oh yeah oh
yeah oh that's what you want to see what
are you two slamming in there come on
slap it okay it doesn't want to slap in
there wait do not touch a goddamn thing
oh wait who else is wait here dad what
would I touch restarting the server come
on get it why is this not going in oh
yeah that arm is coming out of your
nipple
don't talk about my nipple arm just let
me get this gun look way loaded it'll
have something important right now we
don't need any shenanigans right now
okay like why is this not going in am I
supposed to like something or is your
magazine going in I'm struggling to get
it into a position where it could but it
didn't in the one time when I was
moderately close to that being a thing
there's not like an empty magazine you
have to eject right don't know you would
see it's longer than the gun and seems
it seems to have an object of some sort
okay this idea has some problems okay
here we go
ahahahaha oh you are done zone album you
are done so the it's my good sir you are
so Dunn's oh wait this is thrilling for
you I know but no honestly it's it's
something what are you doing it I got
the clip is the magazine is in the gun
uh-huh I just have to get it to a point
where I can grab it so I'm gonna put
[Applause]
bear with me when you blew yourself up
playing the wrong game you know I had
it's been selected alright well I was on
grenade last time I thought it would
have chain it would have stayed but
apparently it did not all right should
we try and get all into the same
game-mode yeah okay okay
some ways shootout that makes sense
um haha I said what victim I won it said
my scrim wins oh alright multiplayer I
choose wow what do you know
Wade was right about everything I never
said you were I never said you were
right those does ignorant Bob Wow Oh
why's your face broken so fast at that
still not even into the fog the [ __ ]
well I'm in the box why are you so slow
oh you're terrible at this number you're
done zone now nah honestly if I remember
the trick is mostly to not touch the
grenades if I remember what do you mean
you got touch of grenades to know I
touch the grenades to kill yourself what
do you mean
here's what I do I grab the box with one
hand all right well you're lifting with
the hand you grab with I don't do that
well I mean I'm not doing it not you why
are you talking to me isn't it although
it's not why does your box lid close but
you have a grenade cuz I opened it why
did you close it I didn't grab it he
closed it why are you questioning me
you're dead because I'm too good with
the grenade oh god it could shaved it on
the best on the best there ever was fine
my fingers so in this ring oh yeah okay
well that thing I said about just
letting you guys get thicker go why
didn't it go go i [ __ ] win - go
sounds like a new problem making fun of
me are you having trouble that wasn't
about you I'm trying to oh [ __ ] are you
so fast blue my grenades away from ours
do you have in hand simulator what the
[ __ ] you guys have forgotten my cheap
strats I told you about last time we
played I don't pull the pin on the
grenade I grab it shake it as hard as
possible and then throw it okay alright
well joke's on you you told us your epic
strategy is gonna get a face full of me
that's you good choice don't even know
how you opened the box so quickly with
my right hand lift up a little bit
switch hands stick that hand under the
box lid no switch hands back let go put
that under the box lid flip up the lid
grab grenade [ __ ] up
shake shake shake Marcus dies
Oh mark I swear to God I swear to God I
can't even get the freakin box open
anymore
where's my head funnier confused I am
really shaking there we go
it's out of there so I gotta do is you
idiot do not understand how a grenade
works oh [ __ ] I don't understand our
grenade works no I didn't
no that's not what stop laughing that's
not what happened it doesn't explode
what starts the process I'm not wrong
you're really right I am aware I'm right
if the if the thing doesn't fly off how
it works you guys look well I see how
much I know about grenades see that yeah
what will eat the hammer I'm holding the
hammer yeah so what and then of you
actually do want to practice this hang
on if you do like a quick way to restart
research
oh [ __ ] hey mark you'll figure it out I
know how this works I know I'm just
giving you I'm saying giving you credit
I'm saying you'll figure it out I can
start opening the box before the games
even started what the [ __ ] open when it
was on - on the go that's why you Oh
close the lid because you'll hit the lid
I just have to know you guys know that I
wasn't in the situation where you yeah
buddy oh yeah yeah yeah I didn't throw
the think I throw the pen I feel like
you're ignoring you know I didn't think
I need you guys to say in very clear
words that mark yeah you totally
understand what's happening okay
there we go okay now I'm gonna get you
guys mmm
take that mark no Cody
you guys already blowed all of my
grenades out of my box trying to play
the game I'm trying to play the game
mark I'm so upset
I'm trying to play the game both
acknowledge that you understand how
grenades to be able to throw a grenade
not against the guy who's played like
39,000 episodes this Bob do you don't
degrades no I don't have any [ __ ] aids
let's just call it a draw all right well
as Mark loses why what why why would
that be don't you want I don't know
don't don't don't read into it
I don't read in it I don't read you know
I know you don't read that's why I'm
tonight explains why I didn't know how
grenades worked wait oh I'm sorry I
didn't but grenade 101 stupid idiot what
do you mean what do you mean it was
coming right for you listen to my words
it's coming right for you I'm not
talking about proximity I'm talking
about direction right
no it's Baxter was approaching wait we
already acknowledged you know how
grenades work obviously obviously just
go down my [ __ ] hands I swear to God
I just saying
try not to kill yourself I'm trying to
help you out but you know I just I swear
I swear
I hate grade because you know take
another grenade no I was doing it the
right way I want to invoke a rule in a
word I say the shake rule is stupid we
need to pull the pin I was getting good
at pulling the pin Oh your cheat you're
cheating
wait you're cheating you're cheating is
the Wars of modern warfare change you
know the rules of engagement are there
to like stop unnecessary for your safety
more no they're not listen I you you're
cheating both of you I'm not eating okay
I want a solemn promise that you guys
are gonna pull the Rings okay cuz that's
the way the game is meant to be played
okay okay that feels fair yeah feels
good good good then we'll do that are
you out of grenades wid I am do you
still have some yes yes this is my dear
yeah finish this put my heart and put
your hands in the air like you just
don't care
okay and then further further
hey okay so this is solid bad time right
this is solemn but uh next round solemn
vow starts what solemn vow wait you took
a solemn vow you remember this all about
he said is it fair that we all pull the
pins and we all said yes right yes
that's the vow okay okay all right cool
good all right so we don't have to pull
the pins we just all agree it was fair
to pull the pins right that's not I'm
gonna I'm gonna I think this might
actually kill you we do this one Oh God
that came out what I was trying to turn
it in my hand
that's what cheaters deserve mark taking
a solemn vow I'm solemn vowing yes why
I'm I'm solemn I'm very solemnly vowing
I'm wanting oh go oh yeah dad I don't
think that yeah yeah I didn't that
wasn't supposed to go towards you but I
that was a really good throw to get
weighed that was good that was good it
feels satisfying like playing by the
rule
ah yeah actually yeah I liked it I felt
solemn you know they were just feel
really solemn about something yeah
always
every every day my life is so close to
that hole I know I know wait stop
looking at me you said you didn't want
it's like wait said you got to really
want it
you didn't really play with it once you
had it in there he was kind of yeah you
gotta give it a little foreplay man you
gotta love it a little bit
I don't tell me how to love holes what
what is happening my might listen other
yeah all that's booked that's right here
we go oh come on that's kind of a noodle
arm throw did you just call him a noodle
arm boys it's hooked boys okay yeah
that's cool it's it's hooked my dudes
wait I've killed you so many times this
round I have never felt more dead in my
life okay all right I I wouldn't solemn
I would have had that I would have had
that what I do with my mouse not many of
you know this but what I do is I have a
wrist pad so I operate my mouse from
wrist control
it lets me gets like fine control but
for the throw you need like aggressive
motion and ice that's what I wasn't able
to get but you know I took away the the
I took it away so now I'm gonna be able
to get this much more solemnly so you
know it's not my fault that I didn't
throw it right because I did in all
honesty I did but the game didn't
register because of the way I like for
sensitive controls mark this is not
intentionally aimed at you I apologize
what's it what's not aimed at me but I
don't know why that fingers doing that
thing that it's - oh you are you are you
being rude to me yeah but it's not
intentional I don't know just the way I
just I hold grenades hey mark this is
for you buddy
no yeah well whatever hang on doesn't
matter no no I did it for mark well god
I friends now here we go okay because I
know you feel about Wade's cheating ways
Oh what you son of a blush you actual
bastard Jake but how did
not kill you is the question that matter
does it because you're dead now
hey guess who's winner game everybody
cheated in my game crashed what was he
[ __ ] doing it that's what you guys he
wagged was he weighed waggling I waited
til you threw one before I win back
who's that's what you get is what you
get
[Music]
you